[Music]
if you had to rank yourself against
others based on a specific trait
what would it say about how you see them
and how they see you
we brought together five couples and had
the boyfriends rank themselves based on
how attractive they think they are then
we invited their girlfriends to
rearrange them this is ranking
my name is calvin
that's a bad idea that's drama right
there
people are gonna rake their boyfriends
oh yeah he looked better than mine
yeah you sexy
and
i grew canvas um my name is ryan i'm 25
i work for a tech company my name is
dominic i'm 21. i'm a full-time student
and i'm working in tech consulting
imagine your girlfriend's part of the
five women who put you in the last place
and then this video gets uploaded and
then y'all break up a couple months
later yeah
yeah you're gonna have to live the rest
of your life knowing an ex-girlfriend
got you one [ __ ] and youtube all it
would be like
out of five people you're fifth
[Music]
that's an eternal listen i've taken else
you already know about me in the bushes
but that she didn't have it on camera
nobody we have it on cartoon
that it did happen
that was art that's this is humiliation
i get that same thing
you're busting my room saying oh are you
watching porn oh is this hentai i'm like
this is art
you [ __ ] masturbating goblin
hey man you know what i told you last
time
you can't masturbate with good posture
you always gotta hunch over like this
that's why i admire women arching their
back looking like
[ __ ] be like
lord of the rings yeah girls really
position they're in this keynote yeah
yeah yeah
those are me like bodybuilding
the girls
[Music]
it's the white eyes yeah i never had
yeah
guys about this guy's googly island
got that yo
yeah
guys never like masturbate i never
masturbated and rolled my own eyes why i
went girls
all the time
when they hit that spot i never
masturbated over that i was like oh [ __ ]
i'm so good at this
that's
just kidding but yeah it never happened
oh you having reminiscent right there
i've definitely had a few
i've had a few uh
good wings i shouldn't be doing this
i shouldn't be watching this yeah that
happens often yeah hi my name is mark
vega i turn 28 today i'm a youtuber a
real estate agent and a actor
uh my name is mika i'm 21. i'm in the
process of getting my license to drive
the commercial trucks the bigger rigs
who do you guys think they will find
i would say this was his guys like this
guy how's
there's something appreciative about a
[ __ ] 645 guy being like oh yeah
you're uh you're kind of handsome down
there oh yeah
i'm sure you uh get some play up there
with the peasants yeah and the riff raff
i really want i really appreciate it if
the guy's like
me i appreciate the [ __ ] out of that i'd
be like
okay my dude live your life i think this
guy feels himself any [ __ ] in
2022 who still gels his hair probably a
little conceited
and says bro a lot i'ma just take again
can i say myself
oh my god oh my god oh my god
how is that possible a hundred no no
you're a wizard you're a wizard did he
say myself he said that he said myself
you almost asked you called it you that
that was
okay let me let me tell you guys on the
play
stop it
you you did great stop it stop it
okay
this is my experience of life right
most attractive dudes i know know
they're very attractive but they've
learned that people see them as
conceited if they come at you overtly so
they know to mask that a lot out very
attractive women do the same thing
but but we all know right we know
they're bullshitting the people who are
generally the most conceited of all
are average dudes who are super
disillusioned about their [ __ ]
attractiveness people who spend so much
time in the mirror they've literally
lied to themselves about the reflection
they see or the feedback that they get
and that's what this guy strikes me as
for him to say the most attractive out
of everyone there is crazy to me
probably me
i'm out of that
i appreciate it
i'd appreciate it if it was the
actual handsome guy but
but you know what though let me hear his
reasoning because it might be perfectly
logical and i might have just been
jumping the gun
one minute there you go yeah yeah there
you go
i was saying you look like andrew
garfield kind of oh i get that one
actually yeah yeah i just realized you
look like edward collins oh i've gotten
that yeah i see that twilight yeah yeah
yeah i can see that alex wasabi
we're gonna get this every day yeah by
the way i like the beard i like the
beard it works well on you
too dude i can't grow a beard did you
get a fresh cut just recently too two
days ago
for the cameras yeah i like your hair i
was gonna get it i usually get like a
fade right here like zero but i just put
my hair down i'm jealous i love it yeah
yeah
do you guys think your girlfriends found
you attractive
i would say yes because first day we met
we actually kissed already
when i first met her she was working at
this restaurant and she asked me out on
a date so
she definitely thought i was attracted
to i don't know that's just yo no she
was working and she asked me out so
yeah she agrees with me
i don't know
that's why i die let's find out i can't
wait to see this i'm not sure actually
because she kind of look he um
almost left me on red and almost like
and then you replied with i'm 6'4 she
went hi
hello
hello
hello
i'm 6'4 hi
you know your face is your money maker
the first thing that people see and you
have to take care of that i understand
and it's not for everybody it's not
everybody that know how to do it and
know how to take care of their skin well
that's a wonderful timing that you have
here because we have this wonderful
project that i'm using to clear off
everything in my skin and my pores th
henley what i would suggest you to do
i suggest you to take and to start with
the level one system it's a box what
kind of products i got in the box i'm
about to tell you right now well first
of all they have a face wash you don't
want to get all in the nooks and
crannies all the pores get all the grime
out boom they have a moisturizer as an
spf uh 20 in there you don't have a
little protection from the sun they have
instruction with the products that
you're gonna use to tell you when to use
the products how to use the products go
on the link below right now click on the
link below and save 30 off your first
purchase and also you can get a free
gift from th henley i'm just saying if
you wash your booty
wash your beauty
that was genius uh we had a great first
date um so i think so it showed up
really like edgy looking like i had a
um like a sword piercing earring i was
wearing like all black but yeah
the guy on the far left went that worked
hey but listen it worked out so you know
good for him these days i definitely
feel like i dress more like a dad so you
know times have changed
yeah i think i might be in the wrong
spot why why i got to scoot that way a
little bit
because you know my girlfriend agrees
with me you know i feel like he's saying
he's like
i'm a bad [ __ ] no [ __ ] you just bad
that's all [ __ ] use the bag [ __ ]
it's a toss-up for me
yeah yeah because you look like andrew
garfield kind of yeah it's like the dude
from twilight yeah oh there you go it's
like what actors oh now i see yeah
yeah real quick what if we just did a
ranking based off of only personality
i'll say you won for christmas yeah
you're kind of you really you too you
two move up but like in front of us or
like yeah push us like us
we can still figure out the order yeah
definitely up yeah do you think you
should be more
hey that's a toss-up for me too you know
like i like your personality you're
pretty cool
i think this should be a little up too
cause you're really chilling yeah yeah
yeah that's why i was thinking that too
i would move you up in front of me okay
honestly work that's just a subtle way
to put him last yeah yeah i would put
you in front of me
i mean instead of in terms of
personality they're not lying no they're
not lying
[Music]
for me it's more than physicality
obviously yeah attractiveness so like
personally i wouldn't be attracted to
him off the bat but he talks really well
like the way he talked about you and the
way he presents himself was really sweet
so i would rank him up top for sure
maybe like one or two okay so number one
of course
number two because of this hair and
we're the same color so automatic
uh you know minority vote what's up well
that's how some people chose obama yeah
yeah yeah that's facts but we're not
talking about the president but
actually it's even worse than what chose
the president
that's true
i honestly play him as number one for
the most part yeah i agree yeah yeah for
sure
um you know birthday okay
[Laughter]
obviously my man will be right that's
number one
good but
number two
i say him yeah yeah
because he the way he comes out he seems
so friendly too seems like the type of
guy that would be just a nice boyfriend
would i feel
like
women say
he looks friendly
it's actually
just gonna be careful what i say
you're friendly
or is it just the fact that
enough are safe
i think it's just safe
and women look for some like you know
you have your your your excitement your
thrill the one that gets your juices
going and then some people really desire
security and safety and so they'll look
for that and so when they see someone
who's a little bit more
disarming a little bit more like huh
they find that endearing to some degree
like a little brother
not necessarily like i feel like
whenever they like security
they they also like
the bad boy thing
right and when they understand that that
bad boy is not gonna arm them then they
feel secure that's why that bad boy you
know the tame beast
everybody likes those two things but
there's different points in your life
where you're gonna seek one out over the
other fair
right and so some people based off their
childhood
right maybe they were traumatized by a
bunch of stuff they seek out security
above us they don't care about how good
you are they just want somebody they can
feel safe with that makes sense right so
some people just look for different
things also sometimes what you look for
changes over time and so definitely
that's why you might have gone through a
bunch of bad boys who you end up
marrying somebody who's a little bit
more safe life because there's a
stability and security there so same
thing with dudes
you might be interested in bimbos early
on then after a while like i can't do
this anymore drop my [ __ ] he talks too
much i'm gonna go with my boyfriend
first
pretty biased whatever um i think he has
to give himself some more credits i'll
give him a second yeah yeah he has a
personality it's good
but i also like calvin yeah the way he
said um i learned my confidence from you
yeah that was really sweet
okay
no hard feelings i think everybody's
beautiful and gorgeous
um number one specifically because the
vibe
the jewelry the head bop when he was
listening to music
number two because of the way he
presented himself and talked about his
significant other was just so cute
number three funny
outgoing happy number four
kind of quiet
but fun
and then number five um
no hard feelings like no one's a five in
my eyes but that wasn't just my personal
taste
[Music]
number one i mean what a stud right
um number two just really love the hair
the style and super funny
number three the style very cool looking
the style
number one this is what you said number
one
asian number two
asian number three closest thing to
asian white number four
you could be half asian number five um
that's awesome
okay i only say this i'm gonna tell you
why i say this because i do know
i'll tell you why that because i i i do
know some women yeah who only dation
yeah which is fine
um
it's like that
yeah all right
only dictations yeah but then again that
don't put her on blast because we don't
know which one
facts so nobody's gonna know what
nobody's gonna know except for the asian
dudes we're getting
i'm still taking this off
kind of energetic like he's got some
vibe that like seems really really cool
like mysterious you kind of want to know
more
and then five still very attractive just
not my type to each their own
the closest thing
is that it's an asian beater
hey shout out to asians though y'all
deserve something yay listen let's go
[Music]
personally it is what it is i'm only
trying to impress
one person so it didn't really bother me
too much
[Music]
we weren't wrong based off what the guys
did women did personality yeah because
they did they did but we did that before
listening to them yes well they did it
based off hearing the guys yeah and so
they had to ask to graduate number two
for example because they're just like
you're too arrogant yeah oh i said it
if he would have just shut his mouth and
nobody knew anything about him the women
would have ranked much higher yeah
definitely but because he spoke yeah and
they're including personality and
attractiveness and that's a whole wild
card
[Applause]
i thought it was gonna be like three or
four honestly just because i knew i was
lacking a little height but i guess they
messed with my vibe i guess
i never thought it was going to be
ranked number one never and i i really
thought um dominic was gonna be number
one i don't know i think um
they just appreciated my hair
and the fact that i look like
edward cullen i just appreciate that you
know
the guy raided me higher hey boys
[Laughter]
i just tell you man i think especially
in north america in general there's like
a huge disdain for anybody who's like
overly confident instantly turns people
off especially if they feel like you're
not deserving of it it's even worse it's
not just american that's a lot of
a lot of people are like that
i feel like in other cultures they value
it way more or they appreciate it
a lot of african cultures they like when
people are like
i can see it they like it when you start
your stuff in fact like so if you're
here for example
wearing bling all this other stuff here
not well seen you go to other places
they do like that [ __ ] they do like you
flaunting them
well just like just just just in america
in general
if you think black culture and
mainstream culture or black culture and
like for example white people
we
usually floss a bit more
yeah we like flavor we light flavor
yeah yeah i gotta be decked out all
black but my [ __ ] my mom my shoes gonna
be red red yeah order grills or this and
that and when i step and with this drip
on the white side i could say oh you got
a lot of confidence oh you're
okay you're wearing grills not
ironically all right
you know you take latin land culture and
machismo
yeah they do like that they like that
[ __ ] right so yeah
where do they like a man who's feeling
himself in most places
i feel like it's a very like more sort
of western notion of like humbleness is
super encouraged in that regards but
like yeah while i was growing up and
stuff like that they used to love people
who like would ride around in really
nice cars and do all that extra stuff
like yeah that was that was seeing this
saw that yeah yeah so just a bit of
difference but it was um
that's all that's all i got to say let
us know what you guys think in the below
do you disagree agree we want to hear
from you